David Boder: [In English] Munich, September 21, 1946 at a displaced peoples camps in for Latvian, Lithuanians and Estonians. The interview is Mr. Janis Kalnietis, 46 years old.
David Boder: [In German] Sind sie lehrer?
Janis Kalnietis: Ja.
David Boder: [In English] He is a teacher here at the school in gymnasium?
Janis Kalnietis: [In German] Nein.
David Boder: [In English] in the elementary school. He just showed me a book which is printed here in Nürnberg with a number of pictures of Latvia, and the final pages are devoted to the so called...of the horrors of the Soviets in Latvia. The question whether they have recorded any of the horrors caused by the Nazis; he says that so far they don’t have the proper material. The name of the book is “Zeme, kas palika ugunis”, “The Land Which Has Remained in Fire”. I asked whether I can buy such a book; he was rather non-committal, but I may see whether I can get a copy. He wants talk in the Latvian, but we will make a trial to get up kind of a report.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну пожалуйста господин Калнитис вы уберите руку с лица и подходите поближе.
David Boder: Э вы мне скажите где вы были когда в первые русские пришли опять пришли в Латвию и что с вами произошло потом, говорите по латышски.
Janis Kalnietis: [In Latvian] Es biju boļševikiem ienākot, uz laukiem vidzemē, biju vidzemē. Tā kā skolotājam man vasaru bija atvaļinājums un es biju savās tēva mājās.
David Boder: [In Russian/German] Ну да, erzählen sie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Скажите все дальше что произашло, но главным образом не то что произашло вообще, а что произошло с вами, все то что с вами случилось лично. Вы понимаете?
Janis Kalnietis: Да, да
David Boder: Ну ходите говорите, вы не ждите чтобы я вас спрашивал.
Janis Kalnietis: На латышском или русском?
David Boder: Давай на латышском языке.
Janis Kalnietis: [In Latvian] Tas notika vasarā, rudenī man bija jāsāk darbs skolā, tad vispirms boļševiki mani atstādināja no amata, es biju skolas pārziņa palīgs, bet mani degradēja par skolotāju pēc tam mani izsvieda pavisam no skolas, bet tā kā viņiem vajadzēja kori ar diriģenta un tāda viņiem nebija tad pieņēma mani atpakaļ par skolotāju ar noteikumu, ka es vadu viņu kori. Tā es arī paliku kādu laiku par skolotāju, bet pāris mēnešus strādādams es jutu, ka man visur tiek sekots un skolas pārzinis bija iecelts komunists, kurš rakstīja speciālu burtnīcu par tiem skolotājiem, kurus viņš turēja aizdomās par boļševismu, boļševiku režīmam nepiemērotiem un nejauši vienam skolotājam bija laimējies šo burtnīcu ieraudzīt uz galda un dažas lapas izlasīt un tur bija teikts, kad Kalnietis tanī dienā tikos un tikos izgājis no mājas, redzēts runājamies ar to un to uz ielas, tad domājams ka pie viņa valsts svētku dienā novembrī ir bijuši tādi un tādi viesi un tikos un tikos aizgājuši vārdu sakot bija, es redzēju, ka es tieku izspiegots.
David Boder: [In Russian] Продолжайте.
Janis Kalnietis: [In Latvian] Negaidījis, nenogaidījis vairs tālāk, nenogaidījis vairs tālāko notikumu es nolēmu pazust doties mežos un to arī izdarījām vairāki kopā. Visu pārējo boļševiku laiku es pavadīju mežā un vāciem ienākot tikai iedrošinājos no meža nākt laukā un laikam biju darījis pareizi, jo pretējā gadījumā man ceļš būtu arī vedis uz Sibīriju.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну и скажите теперь, что случилось когда большеви...когда советы ушли из Латвии, каким образом они ушли.
Janis Kalnietis: [In Latvian] Kad boļševiki no Latvijas gāja projām, tad pēc manam domām mēs gaidījām atsvabināšanu no boļševiku terora un ar lielu prieku noraudzījāmies kā mūsu zemē ienāk mūsu atsvabinātāji vācieši, bet šīs cerības mūs dažu dienu laikā izkūpēja, jo pirmais solis ko vācieši darīja bija Rīgas ielu pārdēvēšana piemēram Brīvības bulvāri pārdēvēja par Hitlera ielu un Fon der Goltsa iela radās jo Golts bija mūsu niknākais ienaidnieks tūkstotš deviņi simti deviņpadsmitajā gadā pret kuru mēs tikām asinis ziedojuši. Un viņa vārdā tika nosaukta viena no lielākajām Rīgas ielām. Tas bija mums spļāviens seja vismaz personīgi es to tā izjutu un visa latviešu doma pēkšņi svērās atkal par ļaunu atbrīvotājiem pēdiņas, vāciešiem.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну тогда с начала.
David Boder: Да передите теперь на руский язык если можите.
Janis Kalnietis: Да но немножко.
David Boder: Так, но и скажите же, что ещё тогда произашло с вами лично, вы что в школе преподавали?
Janis Kalnietis: Я преподавал пение в школе
David Boder: A ха
Janis Kalnietis: пение и в последнее время тоже историю.
David Boder: а ха, ну хорошо значит. Что немци вообще сделали там?
Janis Kalnietis: Немци позволяли работать дальше, но в школу, школу взяли для войск, войсков и мы должны были и работать в одной гаражия, шесть сот
David Boder: школа
Janis Kalnietis: да школа была в одной гаражия, шесть сот учеников и двадцать три учителя работали м...в четырёх сменах каждый день, значит трудно было так но работать можно
David Boder: Какие часы была каждая смена?
Janis Kalnietis: Как?
David Boder: Какие часы была каждая смена? Ну в котором часу первая смена началась?
Janis Kalnietis: У в семь, в семь часов утра началось и поздно вечером кончилось, целый день работали.
David Boder: Сколько часов каждая смена?
Janis Kalnietis: Три четыре часа каждая смена.
David Boder: Так, ну дальше.
Janis Kalnietis: Особенно трудно было в истории работать,
David Boder: Почему?
Janis Kalnietis: не как не могли мы детям не смели объяснять девятнадцатого года, когда немци на нас напали в Латвию, они не позволяли детям сказать то что было правдой.
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: Наш.
David Boder: Можете по латышски. Вас что?
Janis Kalnietis: Один из наших учителей который преподавал историю
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: объяснил детям правду
Janis Kalnietis: и сейчас был отпущен
David Boder: и был рассчитан, так его
Janis Kalnietis: и был отпущен,
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: и тогда некто уже не хотел эту историю преподавать.
Janis Kalnietis: Очень многих моих знакомих и друзей из латышской интеллигенции немци посадили в тюрмах, увезли в концентрационных лагерях и мы все время боялись что в нас может быть и нас такая судьба ожидает.
David Boder: Так. Скажите господин ем...Кал э...Калнитис
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: Калнитис, тут в этой колонии есть какие не будь латыши которые были в концентрационных лагерях западных немцов
David Boder: Да, да
Janis Kalnietis: Одного из латышей я знаю.
David Boder: Так, которого немци взяли в концентрационный лагерь.
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: Э...как, нет За что они его взяли
Janis Kalnietis: Значит во время немцов латыши выдали газеты,
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: такие против, против немцев, на шапирографах и так.
David Boder: Секретные газеты
Janis Kalnietis: Секретные газеты и очень многие латыши из интеллигенции работали там и распространяли эти газеты
David Boder: О.
Janis Kalnietis: И тех всех немци хотели в Шверин
David Boder: Э...уничтожить
Janis Kalnietis: уничтожить. Один из наших, в нашем лагере я знаю
David Boder: Так. Ну скажите мне когда не писали эти подпольные газеты против немцев
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: Они что были про русских или нет. Как это было?
Janis Kalnietis: Просто латышские националисты.
David Boder: Они были нацистские националисты?
Janis Kalnietis: Латышские националисты.
David Boder: Так, они были против немцев, но они небыли и за русских?
Janis Kalnietis: Против немцев и против русских.
David Boder: Ах так это было.
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: А скажите у вас были какие не будь партизаны?
Janis Kalnietis: В Латвии?
David Boder: Да.
Janis Kalnietis: Да во время партизаны в Латвии работали и во время сорокового года значит под большевиками
David Boder: Но с большевиками или против большевиков?
Janis Kalnietis: Против большевиков
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: Во время большевиков.
David Boder: Так они, они воевали против большевиков.
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: Так, и потом?
Janis Kalnietis: И в немецкое время, против немцев.
David Boder: Они просто были прямо латышские националисты.
Janis Kalnietis: Латышские националисты и все которые не хо...м...силой которых принудили в немецкую армию но не хотели в армию пойти так их было очень многою
David Boder: Да, ну скажите мне вот что, это вы жили в коком городе?
Janis Kalnietis: В Руене.
David Boder: Руена, это как по русски назывался?
Janis Kalnietis: Руена, также.
David Boder: Руен. Где это в?
Janis Kalnietis: В Эстонской границе.
David Boder: У Эстонской границы, но вы из Латвии, нет?
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: Вы Латвия, и знали вы что не будь что немци делали с евреями?
Janis Kalnietis: В моем городе было очень мало евреев, как я думаю только четырнадцать человек, но тех всех я очень хорошо это знаю, только датуми я не знаю сказать,
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: но я знаю что этих всех четырнадцать евреев немци собрали увезли недалеко девять километров от города и там ночю застреляли и похоронили в лесу. Это все, это все уж видели и знали что,
David Boder: Что случилось.
Janis Kalnietis: Что там случилось Хотели принудить и Латышских полицистов, чтобы те повезли расстрелять но те все убежали некого немци не нашли который хотел бы помочь им, и сами повезли в тяжелой машине и расстреляли это очень хорошо все знают
David Boder: А скажите ка во времена Ульмана
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: евреи были свободны в Латвии?
Janis Kalnietis: Да во время Ульмана все были свободны.
David Boder: Но а почему говорят что им заставляли продавать свои дома латышам?
Janis Kalnietis: Но этого я не знаю.
David Boder: Вы не знаете.
Janis Kalnietis: Этого я не знаю. Я так...
David Boder: Я же говорил то что в Америке говорили.
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: Что во времена Ульмана когда он распустил парламент они приходили к евреям и сказали чтобы они продали свои дома латышским гражданам что они не хотят чтобы евреи владели домами и так далее, вы знаете что не будь об этом?
Janis Kalnietis: Но я видел что во время Ульмана только некоторые большие фабрики перешли в руках, в руках латышского правительства, но о приватных я не знаю тоже все лавки в Риге в других городах все постояли так же как и прежде всего
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: Но Ульман хотел такую политику я думаю вывести, чтобы все большие заводы пошла в руки правительства независимости от этот, этот владелец есть еврей или немец или русский или латыш, независимости от того, я думаю что такая была политика Ульмана.
David Boder: Скажите мне вот что, во времена Ульмана и во времена латышского правительства и свободы, что сделали с немецкими имениями? Разделили эти имения или немецкие бароны их всё держали?
Janis Kalnietis: Эти разделили уж в первые два года латышской свободы
David Boder: А ха.
Janis Kalnietis: каждый из новых латышских крестьян, которые в войну в войне был получил, десять, пятнадцать, двадцать, тридцать гектаров как каждый все немецкие имущества были разделены.
David Boder: Но у вас же остались какие немецкие бароны, нет?
Janis Kalnietis: Немецких барон осталось очень немного, но те же самые тоже получили также двадцать, тридцать гектаров и сами должны были работать так как и латыши работали.
David Boder: Ну а скажите когда немци пришли. Старались они опять забрать латышские земли или оставили они это всё в покое?
Janis Kalnietis: Немцы кажется не поспели во время войны но что они это думали вывести это было совсем ясно. Например в школах эта политика вышла на то чтоб латышам остались только нижние школы и такие практичные школы и что мы долж...мы э...больше могли бы быть служанками
David Boder: Слугами
Janis Kalnietis: Слугами немцев
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: Это политика ясно было видно но они не имели довольно времени всё это вывести
David Boder: Ну а что сделали они с Рижским университетом?
Janis Kalnietis: Немци.
David Boder: М хм...
Janis Kalnietis: Я не был в Риге я был в провинции и хорошо не знаю
David Boder: А ха...
Janis Kalnietis: Не могу говорить
David Boder: Не можете сказать об этом. Ну а потом скажите что с вами случилось когда немци стали уходить? С вами лично?
Janis Kalnietis: Уходить?
David Boder: Даю
Janis Kalnietis: Я был это осеню, я был опять в работе в школе
David Boder: Да.
Janis Kalnietis: И в Руене пришел приказ от немецкого коменданта что все должны наш город оставить.
David Boder: Все жители.
Janis Kalnietis: Все жители.
David Boder: Да.
Janis Kalnietis: И так и я сделал один воз и поехал но далеко не попал воз один танк разбил и пошли дальше пешком.
David Boder: Как танк разбил?
Janis Kalnietis: Не счастье было ночью, ночью.
David Boder: Вас что лошадь была?
Janis Kalnietis: Лошадь убили и все немци разграбили мои одежду и всё и я пошел так
David Boder: Сколько вас человек было в семье?
Janis Kalnietis: В семье?
David Boder: Да.
Janis Kalnietis: Э у меня жена отец и мать.
David Boder: А ха, детей не было с вами.
Janis Kalnietis: Детей не было.
David Boder: Ну, а теперь скажем немножко короче в эти четыре минуты мы эмем можим?
Janis Kalnietis: Да.
David Boder: И хотя я не люблю вас торопить, мы можем идти дальше. Скажите ка вот что вы значит тогда попали из Латвии, куда?
Janis Kalnietis: Из Латвии мене посылали в Готнхафен
David Boder: А ха
Janis Kalnietis: и от тудого в Брумбэрг. Это большой город в Вестпрейсене
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: В прежней Польской границе.
David Boder: Так, и что вы там делали?
Janis Kalnietis: Там мене положили в одной фабрике, столярной фабрике как топителя ночью.
David Boder: Да.
Janis Kalnietis: Должен был кочегаром печи топить.
David Boder: Так.
Janis Kalnietis: И там я работал два месяца потом опять удрали от туда немци взяли меня с собой и я попал здесь в Бурнавия, мне здесь меньше нено...Бурнаве. Это не далеко от Минхенов.
Janis Kalnietis: Там поставили меня в больниция работу каменные угли должен был.
David Boder: А где ваша жена?
Janis Kalnietis: Жена в Латвии осталась, мы небыли вместе.
David Boder: У вас жена осталась в Латвии?
Janis Kalnietis: Осталась в Латвии, и теперь.
David Boder: А ваши родители?
Janis Kalnietis: Тоже в Латвии.
David Boder: Так что вы один.
Janis Kalnietis: Только один.
David Boder: Вы пишите, получаете письма от жены?
Janis Kalnietis: Не хочу писать.
David Boder: А через «Красный крест»?
Janis Kalnietis: Боюсь.
David Boder: Боитесь. Так что она знает что вы живы или не знает?
Janis Kalnietis: Не знает.
David Boder: Вы не пробовали писать через Америку, не чего?
Janis Kalnietis: Не пробовал, боюсь. Я знаю что с сорокового года, который получил письмо где не будь из аусланд, тот значит пропал, потому я боюсь писать. Не относительно себя но относительно других.
David Boder: Ну а скажите ка, вот чтоб а потом где вас освободили?
Janis Kalnietis: Здесь в Германии?
David Boder: Да.
Janis Kalnietis: Бурнавие, там в больнице где я работал.
David Boder: И кто пришли туда?
Janis Kalnietis: Американцы пришли.
David Boder: Ну а скажите ка что вы собераетесь теперь делать?
Janis Kalnietis: Это трудно ответить, но я думаю я должен ожидать пока все объяснится.
David Boder: То есть как вы это думаете?
Janis Kalnietis: Моими родителями, женой с Латвией в общем.
David Boder: Но а вы думаете что скоро будет какая перемена в Латвии?
Janis Kalnietis: Ну что я могу думать?
David Boder: Не знаю.
Janis Kalnietis: Все та ожидаем, может быть будет какая не будь перемена.
David Boder: Но ведь нельзя же так долго продолжать жить в лагерях, в бараках и так далее. Вед надо же чтобы кокой не будь ваш вопрос разрешился.
Janis Kalnietis: У меня все равно, я только один, я могу работать и всякую физическую работу, я готов на все, готов на все, что только американцы будут
David Boder: Предложат
Janis Kalnietis: предложат, я верю Англии и Америке, я знаю очень хорошо знаю, что все мы латыши только от этих двух народов все хорошее ожидать можем, не от других, это мое мнение.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes spool four hundred fourty two.